It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. OK, so much has already been said about this week's news. And so what we're going to do today is very simple. We have people from all over the country, all walks of life, absorbing the news and getting to talk about what they are feeling and thinking. Some of these people you may agree with, some you will not. This has been a year where it feels like the two sides are so radically far apart. But of course, we all live here in this country together, we are all facing this future together-- what are we feeling right now as we do that? And I'm just going to start right in on our first stop.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本周的新闻已经有了太多评论，所以我们今天要做的很简单。我们汇集了来自全国各地、各行各业的人，让他们畅谈对当下新闻的感受和想法。其中有些人你可能赞同，有些则不然。今年感觉就像是两个阵营在理念上分道扬镳。但当然，我们共同生活在这个国家，共同面对未来——在此时此刻，我们的真实感受是什么？我这就直接进入第一个话题。
Act One, Southern Florida. Our producer Miki Meek met these two police officers. They were both Latino, both voted Obama in 2008, then Romney in 2012, then Donald Trump this week.
第一幕，佛罗里达州南部。我们的制片人米基·米克采访了两位警察。他们都是拉丁裔，2008年都投了奥巴马的票，2012年投给了罗姆尼，而本周则选择了唐纳德·特朗普。
It was Thursday, middle of the night. And I was in the parking lot of a restaurant in South Florida, where these two officers were taking a short break. The news of President Trump had been out for exactly 24 hours, and they were still in shock. The results came in just as they were checking out a burglary at a local business. They turned and said to each other.
那是周四的深夜。我当时就在南佛罗里达一家餐馆的停车场，这两位警官正在休息。特朗普当选总统的消息已经传出整整24小时了，他们仍感到震惊。就在他们处理一起当地企业的入室盗窃案时，选举结果出来了。他们转过身对彼此说了这样一句话。
This is almost as good as the Dolphins winning the Super Bowl. You know?
这简直跟海豚队赢得超级碗差不多了，你懂吗？
Yeah, I didn't know. I looked at the Miami Dolphins. The last time they won the Super Bowl, 1974.
是啊，我当时还不明白。我查了一下迈阿密海豚队，他们上一次赢得超级碗还是1974年的事了。
We never expected anything. Just all of a sudden it happened.
我们从没预料到会这样。一切就这么突然发生了。
This is Nick. He and his partner Alex said they'd talk to me as long as I didn't use their real names or say what police department they worked for. Also, we had to kind of hide behind their SUV, just in case other cops drove by. Nick and Alex aren't supposed to talk to the press. But like a lot of police officers, the last couple of years have been pretty rough for them. And hearing Donald Trump be called President Trump, it calmed them. Here's Alex.
这位是尼克。他和搭档亚历克斯说，只要我不使用他们的真实姓名，也不透露他们效力的警察局，他们就愿意跟我聊聊。另外，我们还得躲在他们的SUV后面，以防有其他警察开车路过。尼克和亚历克斯是不允许接受媒体采访的。但像许多警察一样，过去几年对他们来说相当难熬。听到“唐纳德·特朗普总统”这个称呼，他们感到了一种慰藉。下面是亚历克斯的话。
Right now is what we're thinking of, it's-- he's going to install members of his cabinet that are going to be more law and order.
我们现在的想法是——他将任命内阁成员，这些人会更注重法律与秩序。
Then Nick jumped back in.
随后尼克插话道。
It was actually just a relief, like saying, God, maybe now there's a change in directions. Maybe now it's not OK to go out and riot in the streets and burn down buildings, saying, [BLEEP] the police. Maybe there will be hope. Maybe somebody's up there that could change that and say, hey, enough is enough.
这确实是一种解脱，就像是在说，天哪，也许现在方向要变了。也许以后在街头骚乱、烧毁建筑物、喊着“去他妈的警察”就不再是被默许的了。也许会有希望。也许上面终于有人能站出来说，嘿，适可而止吧。
Here's an example of how they're treated. The night before, on election night, they stopped by a restaurant. There were a lot of people standing around the TV, and Trump was on, giving his victory speech.
这是他们受到怎样对待的一个例子。选举前一天晚上，他们停在一家餐馆前。当时很多人正围在电视机前，特朗普正在发表胜选演说。
And we asked to turn up the volume so we could listen to whatever was said. And one particular person said, no, we're not going to raise the volume on the TV.
我们请求把音量调大，好让我们听听他在说什么。结果有个特定的人说，不行，我们不会调大电视音量的。
Someone else reached over and turned it up for them.
另一个人伸手帮他们调大了音量。
That person got extremely upset and said, why are you raising the volume for these people? And the person just shook their heads and walked away, like in disbelief. Like, I can't believe we've got to let these cops listen to what the president has to say.
那个人变得非常生气，说，你们为什么要为这群人调大音量？而那个人只是摇了摇头走开了，仿佛难以置信。就好像在说，我简直不敢相信我们竟然得让这些警察听总统要说什么。
Like, what's the emotion that you felt?
那么，你感到的那种情绪是什么？
It's kind of like, for many years, you're kind of like down under a rock. And then finally you kind of get used to living down there. You go to any bar, you go to any gathering or barbecue or anything like that, and the first thing, hey, what do you do for a living? And you're like, here we go. And it's like, the last thing I want to tell people is I'm a cop. I'm a firefighter.
那种感觉就像，多年来你一直躲在岩石下面，然后慢慢习惯了那样的生活。你去任何酒吧、聚会或烧烤现场，当别人问你：“嘿，你是干什么的？”你就会想：又要来了。告诉别人我是警察，这是我最不想做的事。我是个消防员。
Is that what you tell people now?
你现在是这样告诉别人的吗？
Firefighter. What else do I tell people? I sell pharmaceuticals. I don't even know. I come up with the weirdest things. But people's demeanor immediately changes.
消防员。我还能说什么？我卖药的。我甚至不知道说什么好。我会编出各种稀奇古怪的借口。但人们的态度会立刻改变。
What does it look like?
那是什么样的表现？
They're just like, oh, oh! Everything changes. Even if they're holding a drink, they'll put it down.
他们会表现出，哦，哦！一切都变了。即使手里拿着饮料，他们也会放下。
Although Nick and Alex were both Obama supporters in 2008, they felt let down by the president and the Democratic Party. They didn't like how policing issues had been handled over the past few years.
尽管尼克和亚历克斯在2008年都是奥巴马的支持者，但他们对总统和民主党感到失望。他们不喜欢过去几年处理治安问题的方式。
It was a lack of support. Obviously it was 100% a lack of support. Basically right now, when a police officer is involved in anything, we are guilty until proven innocent. You're supposed to be for everybody. You're the president of everybody.
这是一种缺乏支持的表现。显然，那是百分之百的缺乏支持。基本上现在只要警察牵涉到任何事情，我们都是有罪推定，直到证明无罪。你应该为所有人服务，你是所有人的总统。
And then during this election, the way he ran and the way he supported Hillary, and Hillary's number one thing was, hey, let's bring on victims of these shootings, let's bring the Black Lives Matter, let's bring out artists that sing against police.
而在这次选举中，他的参选方式和支持希拉里的方式，而希拉里的首要议题就是：嘿，让我们找来枪击案的受害者，让我们找来“黑人的命也是命”运动，让我们找来唱反警察歌曲的艺人。
We're good guys, they kept saying to me. We're not all bad apples. Both Alex and Nick are upfront that Trump has done things that trouble them. All the stuff he's said about women, it shocked them. And also--
“我们是好人，”他们反复对我说，“我们并非都是烂苹果。”亚历克斯和尼克都坦言，特朗普做过一些让他们感到不安的事。他关于女性的所有言论让他们感到震惊。而且——
He's inexperienced. And I think he's very hot-headed. And when you're a man of the power that he is now, any wrong decision could cost a lot. Is he the answer that we're looking for? Who knows?
他缺乏经验。而且我觉得他脾气很暴躁。当你掌握他现在所拥有的权力时，任何错误的决定都可能代价高昂。他是我们正在寻找的答案吗？谁知道呢？
But for the moment, he feels like their best bet.
但目前为止，他感觉是他们最好的赌注。
Miki Meek.
米基·米克报道。
Act Two, Metro North Train. OK, so next we head north. One of our producers, Neil Drumming, talked to somebody who was not happy with the results of Tuesday's election at all and was trying to figure out how to brace herself and think about the coming days.
第二幕，北方铁路列车。接下来我们向北走。我们的制片人尼尔·德鲁明采访了一位对周二选举结果极其不满的人，她正试图设法支撑自己，思考接下来的日子该怎么办。
Wednesday morning, my friend Janelle posted a comment on Facebook. Janelle's a stand-up comedian, so this stood out to me because it wasn't at all funny. But it was a thing a lot of my black friends had been saying on social media in the hours after the election. Her post read, "All the older black people I've spoken to this morning, including my mom, are not surprised. Straight of back, and calm as [BLEEP], so I will strive for the same."
周三早上，我的朋友珍妮尔在Facebook上发了一条评论。珍妮尔是一名脱口秀演员，所以这条动态很引人注目，因为它一点也不好笑。但这却是选举后几小时内，我很多黑人朋友在社交媒体上都在说的话。她的帖子写道：“我今天早上交谈过的所有年长的黑人，包括我妈妈，都不感到惊讶。腰杆挺直，冷静得要命，所以我也会努力做到这一点。”
The next day, I called Janelle to ask her about it. She was on the train headed into New York to do some gigs.
第二天，我打电话给珍妮尔问她这件事。当时她正在去纽约赶演出的火车上。
What did your mom say? Or what did you ask her, and what did she say?
你妈妈说了什么？或者你问了她什么，她是怎么回答的？
Well, my mom is, like, one of those people that stresses out over the littlest [BLEEP]. Like, she watches-- she checks the weather where I live and tells me when storms are coming.
我妈妈是那种连最小的事情都会担心的人。比如，她会查看我住的地方的天气，并提醒我风暴什么时候来。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
So I called her thinking she would be freaking out. I mean, I was freaking out.
所以我打电话给她，以为她会抓狂。我的意思是，我当时快崩溃了。
Wait. What kind of state were you in, first of all?
等等，首先，你当时是什么状态？
Oh, I was-- I didn't sleep all night. Like, I was really feeling real stressed. Like, physical pain stress.
哦，我整晚都没睡。我真的感到非常焦虑，是那种伴随身体疼痛的焦虑。
And then so, when you called your mother, like, how was she on the phone?
那么，当你打电话给你妈妈时，她在电话里表现得怎么样？
She was like, good morning!
她说，早安！
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
I called her thinking she would be even worse than me, and she was so chill that it was surprising. I called her, and I was like, can you believe this? And she was like, you know where we live. That's what she said, you know?
我打电话给她以为她会比我更糟，结果她冷静得让人吃惊。我打电话给她说，你敢相信吗？她说，你知道我们住在哪里。她就是这么说的，你知道吗？
She said, "you know where we live"?
她说，“你知道我们住在哪里”？
Yeah.
对。
Janelle's mother means the United States of America. When she told Janelle "you know where we live," she meant, in a country with a history of racism that runs so deep, you as a black person should not be shocked by the results of this election or anything else you may witness in the near future. Stay cool.
珍妮尔的母亲指的是美利坚合众国。当她告诉珍妮尔“你知道我们住在哪里”时，她的意思是，在一个种族主义根深蒂固的国家，你作为一个黑人，不应该对选举结果或你在不久的将来可能目睹的任何事情感到震惊。保持冷静。
Like, I've heard that sentiment a few times now, and does it make you feel better? Or how does it make you feel?
这种感受我听过几次了，它让你感觉好一点了吗？还是说它让你感觉如何？
It's kind of resigned. I feel like that's how black people are. We're just like, this is how it's gonna be. And you get little moments of reprieve. Like, I guess Obama here and there. But it always comes back. Like, we're just always waiting for the shoe to drop. And it's an ever-present thing that we have to deal with, this feeling of being just always, this [BLEEP] is dangerous is how I feel, you know. [BLEEP] surrounded. So, half the country now, literally half the country, I don't know who the fuck is sitting next to me, closed mouth smiling about this [BLEEP]. You know what I mean?
那是一种宿命感。我觉得黑人就是这样。我们只是觉得，事情就是会这样。你偶尔会得到一点喘息的机会，比如偶尔有个奥巴马。但情况总是会反弹。就像我们总是等着那只靴子掉下来。这种感觉始终存在，我们必须面对这种随时感觉周围很危险的状态，你知道吗？就像被包围了一样。现在半个国家的人，真的是半个国家的人，我不知道坐在我旁边的人是谁，他们正抿着嘴对这破事儿暗自窃喜。你明白我的意思吗？
And you travel a lot, right? You're on the road in all of these towns.
你经常出差，对吧？你在各个城镇奔波。
Yeah. I feel like I'm not under siege, but yeah, I just don't feel safe. Whereas maybe before, I had forgotten. That's what happens. You forget. And then this [BLEEP] happens. And you're like, oh yeah. We know where we live, like my mother says. Like, that's basically what she was saying, like, oh, you forgot.
是的。我觉得我不是在受困，但确实，我就是没有安全感。而在以前，我可能已经忘了。事情就是这样。你会忘记。然后这些破事就发生了。然后你会想，哦，没错。就像我妈妈说的，我们知道我们住在哪里。她基本上就是这个意思，哦，你忘了。
I guess if I was you, I would feel genuine-- I mean, I'm concerned myself. But it's like the notion of going around these towns. Like, you're going to see a lot.
我想如果是我的话，我会感到……我的意思是，我自己也很担心。但要在这些城镇间走动，你会看到很多。
Yeah. I mean, I feel like for most black people, it's not that it's Donald Trump. It's what he represents. You know what I mean? And so there were those-- people have already, they're coming out of the woodwork. You know, there's already been reports of people walking around with black face, walking up to people saying [BLEEP]. Like, we can say that now. Just [BLEEP] jerks-- he represents jerks. They [BLEEP] hate their life and just mad at the world and want to lash out.
是啊。我觉得对于大多数黑人来说，重点不是唐纳德·特朗普，而是他所代表的东西。你明白吗？人们已经开始原形毕露了。已经有报道称有人涂着黑脸走来走去，冲着别人骂脏话。现在这些都能说了。他代表的就是那些混蛋。他们恨透了自己的生活，对世界怀恨在心，想要发泄。
Do you feel emboldened at all? Do you feel bolstered at all by what your mom said? Like, I mean, not just is there a silver lining for you, but are you confident?
你感到被鼓舞了吗？你有没有因为你妈妈的话而感到振作？不仅是那种安慰，你是否有信心？
It just calmed me down. I'm not, like, oh, now everything's going to be fine. I'm still like, people are just on alert. That's how I feel. Like, my body is just on alert. You know what I mean? Danger, danger. Like, that's how my body feels.
这只是让我冷静下来。我并不是说“哦，现在一切都会好起来的”。我依然觉得人们处于警戒状态。这就是我的感受。我的身体处于警戒状态。你知道我的意思吗？危险，危险。我的身体就是这种感觉。
The story from Neil Drumming.
以上故事来自尼尔·德鲁明。
Act Three, Trump Tower. So we've all been witnessing this historic campaign and this election together. But some of us have front-row seats on that. And our producer Karen Duffin went to talk to somebody who actually knows the man who is going to be the president. Here she is.
第三幕，特朗普大厦。我们所有人都在一起见证这场历史性的竞选和选举。但我们中的一些人坐在了前排席位。我们的制片人卡伦·达芬去采访了一位真正了解即将成为总统的那个人。以下是报道。
Last week, a few days before the election, I spent an hour inside Trump Tower, where Donald Trump lives, talking with a friend and neighbor of his, a guy named George Lombardi.
上周，在选举前几天，我在特朗普大厦里待了一个小时，特朗普就住在这里。我和他的朋友兼邻居乔治·隆巴迪聊了聊。
I mean, you're here. I wish your audience can see. I've got two pictures here, one of George Bush, Jr, and one of George Bush, Sr, with myself. I've got also Rudy Giuliani. I've got also the Pope and the Dalai Lama. But anyway--
我的意思是，你在这儿。我真希望你的听众能看到。我这儿有两张照片，一张是小布什，一张是老布什，跟我在一起的。还有鲁迪·朱利安尼。还有教皇和达赖喇嘛。总之——
His living room is littered with pictures of famous people. I couldn't see any of Trump from where I was sitting, but they've been friends for over 25 years now.
他的客厅里堆满了名人的照片。我坐在那儿没看到任何特朗普的照片，但他们已经当了25年多的朋友了。
In June of last year, I said, Donald, are you really serious about this, for president? And he goes, yep. I'm determined. I'm going to do it.
去年六月，我说，唐纳德，你是认真的吗，想当总统？他回答说，是的。我下定决心了，我会做到的。
So he signed on to help his friend out. He organized volunteers for Trump. And when we talked last week, he told me something that at the time seemed to me and probably every pollster in the country a little like wishful thinking.
所以他加入进去帮助他的朋友。他组织了特朗普的志愿者。当我们上周交谈时，他告诉了我一件事，当时在我看来，也可能在全国每一位民调专家看来，都像是一厢情愿。
There might be a big surprise on November 8.
11月8日可能会有一个大惊喜。
Do you think there will be?
你觉得会有吗？
Absolutely. I wouldn't be surprised if we get 48 states.
绝对有。如果我们能拿下48个州，我一点也不会惊讶。
Really?
真的吗？
Trump did not win 48 states. But when I called George this week, it was, of course, a very different conversation.
特朗普并没有拿下48个州。但当我这周打电话给乔治时，情况显然大不相同了。
So, do you want the chance to say, I told you so, Karen?
所以，你想趁机说“我早就告诉过你了”吗，卡伦？
No. Absolutely not. No, no. I mean, honestly, the margin was so small that if I have to give, you know, really responsibility for the victory of Mr. Trump, it's to the Almighty God. Because only God could pull something like that, frankly speaking.
不，绝对不想。不，说实话，差距太小了。如果我必须把唐纳德先生的胜利归功于谁，那是万能的上帝。因为坦率地说，只有上帝才能做到那种程度。
Have you spent time with President-Elect Trump since the victory?
胜利后你和当选总统特朗普见过面吗？
No. I saw him here in the building just as he was walking away from the building going to the Hilton for the speech. At that point, it wasn't yet 100%.
没有。我就在大楼里看到他正走开，准备去希尔顿饭店演讲。那时候结果还不是百分之百确定。
George told Trump, hey, we're having a victory party in the building, and you should come.
乔治对特朗普说，嘿，我们在楼里有庆功会，你应该来。
He looked at Melania and says, well, maybe two minutes. But then the Secret Service said no, you cannot go in this suite. We check the premises first
他看着梅拉尼娅说，嗯，也许两分钟。但特勤局说不行，你不能进入这个套房。我们得先检查场地。
He said, Trump looked at Melania, said maybe two minutes, but the Secret Service said no.
他说，特朗普看着梅拉尼娅，说也许两分钟，但特勤局拒绝了。
So he said, OK, sorry. I'm a slave of these guys now.
所以他说，好吧，抱歉。我现在是这些家伙的奴隶了。
As Trump walked away from him, George says, he seemed serious. Mike Pence too. Like, the gravity of what they might be about to take on was finally sinking in.
当特朗普走开时，乔治说他看起来很严肃。迈克·彭斯也是。仿佛他们即将承担的重任终于压在了心头。
The size and the magnitude of the job ahead, leaving basically the best city of the world for the next four or maybe eight years.
这份工作的规模和重要性，意味着未来四年或八年将离开世界上最好的城市。
How do you think this is going to change him? Like, who do you think he's going to be in four years as a person?
你认为这会如何改变他？四年后他会变成什么样的人？
Mr. Trump and President Trump are going to be remembered as completely different people.
特朗普先生和特朗普总统将被铭记为完全不同的两个人。
George says he can already see this. In Trump's acceptance speech, at the White House with President Obama.
乔治说他已经看到了这一点。在特朗普的胜选演说中，在白宫与奥巴马总统会面时。
It is not the same man that did the campaign. It is a different man.
他已经不是参加竞选时的那个人了。他换了一个人。
Are they going to let him keep his Twitter account?
他们会让他继续使用他的推特账号吗？
Oh, I don't know. You have to ask him that. I have to go.
哦，我不知道。你得去问他。我得走了。
No problem. Thank you.
没问题。谢谢。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
OK, take care.
好，保重。
Bye.
再见。
Karen Duffin did that story. Of course, Donald Trump has started tweeting again.
以上是卡伦·达芬的报道。当然，唐纳德·特朗普已经又开始发推特了。
Act Four, Los Angeles. So the day after the election, the board president of the Los Angeles Unified School District put out this statement. "As students and staff arrive at school today, we know there may be feelings of fear and anxiety, especially within our most vulnerable communities. The district is providing additional supports to those who need it." Latinos make up 74% of the student body there. Our producer Jonathan Menjivar checked in with a teacher who he knows.
第四幕，洛杉矶。选举后的第二天，洛杉矶联合学区董事会主席发表了声明：“随着学生和教职员工今天到达学校，我们知道可能会有恐惧和焦虑的情绪，尤其是在我们最脆弱的社区。学区正为那些需要的人提供额外的支持。”拉丁裔占了那里学生人数的74%。我们的制片人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔走访了一位他认识的老师。
I'm going to let you eavesdrop on this conversation that happened this week.
我让你们偷听一下这周发生的谈话。
So, I mean, is it OK if we just talk normal, Jonathan?
所以，我的意思是，如果我们就正常谈话可以吗，乔纳森？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course.
可以，可以。当然。
Yeah. So, you know, it was a school night last night. So we had to go to sleep.
是啊。你知道，昨晚是上学前一晚。所以我们得睡觉。
This is my cousin, Angelina. I talked to her the day after the election. She's a kindergarten teacher. She teaches in this bilingual program at a school in LA, in Highland Park. There's lots of immigrant families. So Wednesday morning, she got up and learned that Donald Trump would be the next president of the United States. She had 10 parent-teacher conferences scheduled that day and a full day of classes. So, the first conference, she and the parent sit down at 7 o'clock in the morning, and they both start crying.
这是我的表妹安吉丽娜。我在选举后第二天采访了她。她是幼儿园老师。她在洛杉矶高地公园一所学校的双语项目中任教。那里有很多移民家庭。周三早上，她醒来得知唐纳德·特朗普将成为美国下一任总统。她那天安排了10场家长会，还有一整天的课。所以，第一场会议，她和家长在早上7点坐下来，两人都开始哭泣。
We only have 15 minutes to talk. So we kind of said, OK, we're going to do this for five minutes, and then we're going to talk for 10.
我们只有15分钟交谈时间。所以我们说，好吧，我们前5分钟聊这个，然后聊10分钟孩子的情况。
This is how every conference started-- a download on the election, sometimes with crying, and then they'd talk about how the five-year-olds were doing. It was hard to avoid the historic news.
这就是每场会议开始的方式——倾诉选举的事，有时伴着哭泣，然后谈论5岁孩子们的情况。很难避开这个历史性新闻。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's sad what's happening, this mom says. Angelina says, it's hard, it's hard.
“发生这种事真让人难过，”这位妈妈说。安吉丽娜说，很难受，真的很受打击。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But I hope that something good comes out of this, she says. That something good comes out of this, Angelina asks. I hope that he doesn't do everything he says he's going to, that he does something good. We need to think positively, that he'll do something good.
“但我希望从中能有好事发生，”她说。“从中能有好事发生吗？”安吉丽娜问道。“我希望他不要把他说的都做了，他能做点好事。我们需要往积极的方面想，他会做点好事。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So, after Angelina's morning conferences, the kids arrive for school. She picks up her class from the spot where they line up. And one of the kids, he yells out, Donald Trump is president.
所以，安吉丽娜早上的会议结束后，孩子们来上学了。她在排队的地点接回了她的班级。其中一个孩子大喊：“唐纳德·特朗普是总统！”
Then when we got into the classroom, another student said, I'm really afraid because he's going to build a wall. And then another student shouted, he doesn't like brown people. And I have a mixed class. These are not just Latinos in my class. I have a culturally, ethnically diverse classroom.
然后当我们进入教室时，另一个学生说：“我真的很害怕，因为他要建一堵墙。”然后另一个学生大喊：“他不喜欢棕色皮肤的人。”我的班级构成很混杂。不仅仅是拉丁裔。我的班级在文化和种族上是多元的。
And one of my students approached me and said, I'm really sad. I'm leaving the school. And then I said, where are you going? You know, kids move schools. And I said, where are you going to another school? And he said, no, I'm going to Mexico. And then I said, when are you going? He said, I'm going right now.
我的一个学生走过来对我说：“我真的很伤心，我要离开学校了。”我说：“你要去哪儿？”你知道，孩子会转学。我说：“你要转到另一所学校吗？”他说：“不，我要去墨西哥。”我说：“你什么时候走？”他说：“我现在就走。”
And I thought it was kind of like an imaginary conversation. So I said, oh, are you going on vacation? He said, no, I'm leaving because Donald Trump is the president now. And I'm leaving, and I'll never come back. And I'm really going to miss you. And I just was shocked.
我以为那是个虚构的对话。所以我说：“噢，你要去度假吗？”他说：“不，我要离开是因为唐纳德·特朗普现在是总统了。我要走了，再也不会回来了。我会很想你的。”我当时惊呆了。
Angelina doesn't think this kid is actually leaving. It's just a five-year-old digesting the news.
安吉丽娜认为这孩子并不是真的要走。这只是个5岁孩子在消化这些新闻。
And it was constant. It was all day long. And so I had to tell the students, you know, you spend your day at home, and you spend your day with me. And you're protected at home, and you're protected at school. Nothing bad is going to happen to you here. As long as you're home. I mean, you know, I can only speak for home and school, that everything is going to be OK.
而且这种事不断发生。整整一天都是这样。所以我不得不告诉学生们：你知道，你们一天在家里度过，一天和我在一起。在家里你们是安全的，在学校里也是安全的。在这里不会发生坏事。只要你们在家。我的意思是，我只能保证家里和学校，一切都会好起来的。
Angelina says she doesn't know the immigration status of her students. It's just not something you're privy to as a teacher. Trump has said he wants to end illegal immigration entirely. The question is, will he deport the 11 million undocumented immigrants who are already here-- something he said during the campaign but seems to have backed off of now. In the absence of information, the kids and parents, they're filling in the blanks.
安吉丽娜说她不知道学生们的移民身份。作为老师，这不是你该打听的。特朗普说他想彻底结束非法移民。问题在于，他会驱逐这儿已经有的1100万无证移民吗？这是他在竞选中说过的，但现在似乎已经退缩了。在信息匮乏的情况下，孩子们和家长在自我脑补。
It's like, it's hard to believe. How could this be?
那种感觉就像……太难以置信了。怎么会这样？
This is another one of the conferences. This mom told my cousin that she has an autistic brother. You can see it when you look at him. So Donald Trump's imitation of a disabled reporter--
这是另一场会议。这位妈妈告诉我表妹她有个自闭症的弟弟。你看他一眼就能看出来。所以唐纳德·特朗普对残疾记者的模仿——
It's not OK. It's not all right. Yeah, it's not all right. He's just-- who is he to talk to someone like that?
那是不对的。那是不可以的。是的，那不对。他……他算什么东西去那样对别人？
So I've been crying all day with all the parents that I meet.
所以我见到所有的家长都在哭。
Yeah, because it's hard, you know? I have my 11-year-old. And it's hard to explain to him-- he's just, like, how did he win, Mom? And he says, you said he wasn't going to win. And then I said, you know, he just doesn't have that much power, though. I told him, you know, just stay calm. And you know, he's worried about people getting deported, mainly families getting separated. It's just ridiculous.
是啊，因为很难受，你知道吗？我那个11岁的孩子。很难向他解释……他就像，“妈妈，他是怎么赢的？”他说：“你说过他不会赢的。”我说，你知道，他其实没有那么多权力。我告诉他，保持冷静。你知道，他担心人们会被驱逐出境，主要是家庭分离的问题。真是荒唐。
Yeah. OK. Let's do our conference. Thank you. Thank you.
是啊。好吧。我们开始会议吧。谢谢，谢谢。
Angelina told me that this day, processing all of this with the parents, was exhausting. She crawled into bed as soon as she got home.
安吉丽娜告诉我，这一天与家长们一起消化这些信息，让人精疲力尽。她回到家就瘫倒在床上。
Jonathan Menjivar.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔报道。
Act Five, Long Island. So next we have two guys for whom the election was not just about choosing a politician. It was about choosing the new boss. Producer Stephanie Foo hung out with them and recorded their conversation.
第五幕，长岛。接下来是两个人，对他们来说，这次选举不仅是选择一个政客，更是选择新老板。制片人斯蒂芬妮·福和他们待在一起，录下了他们的谈话。
It's the day after the election, and I'm sitting in a diner in Long Island with two Army officers. They're both in the same unit in the reserves. They both have other jobs, but they could be deployed at any time. They've worked together for about two years now. One of them voted for Trump, the other voted for Clinton.
选举后的第二天，我坐在长岛的一家餐馆里，对面是两名陆军军官。他们属于预备役的同一个单位。他们都有别的工作，但随时可能被征召。他们已经一起工作了两年左右。一个投票给了特朗普，另一个投给了克林顿。
Why do you like each other.
你们为什么会喜欢对方？
I don't know. Why do we like each other?
不知道。我们为什么喜欢对方？
We disagree on almost everything.
我们几乎在所有事情上都持不同意见。
You know why? Because I know that he'll have my back, and I'll have his. Regardless of what he believes, although it's ill-founded, most of it, he's awesome. I'd give my life for him.
你知道为什么吗？因为我知道他会支持我，我也会支持他。尽管他的信仰毫无根据——大部分都是这样——但他是个了不起的人。我会为他献出生命。
I'd save my own life. Nah. He knows we're good.
我会选择保命。不，开玩笑的。他知道我们关系很好。
We're good.
我们关系很好。
I'm not using their real names in this story. Tom's the Clinton supporter. He's eating a stack of pancakes and is wearing a periwinkle blue button-down shirt and matching V-neck sweater. Chet is the Trump supporter. He's drinking a double shot of whiskey and wearing flannel over a Millennium Falcon T-shirt. These two guys have a text chain going with a couple other officers in their unit. Sometimes they're planning training exercises, but mostly I get the feeling they're just complaining about their girlfriends and sending each other South Park memes. On the morning after the election, Chet texted Tom.
在这个故事里我不用他们的真实姓名。汤姆支持克林顿。他正在吃一叠薄煎饼，穿着一件紫罗兰蓝色的纽扣衬衫，外面套着同色的V领毛衣。切特支持特朗普。他在喝双份威士忌，在《千年隼》T恤外穿了一件法兰绒衬衫。这两个家伙和单位里其他几个军官有个群组。有时他们在计划训练，但我觉得大部分时间他们只是在抱怨女朋友，发些《南方公园》的表情包。选举后的第二天早上，切特给汤姆发了短信。
I say, hey, you doing OK, Tom? You didn't have an aneurysm, did you?
我说：嘿，汤姆，你还好吗？没得动脉瘤吧？
I go, I'm practicing meditative breathing, preparing for the end.
我说：我正在练习冥想呼吸，为末日做准备。
So then I respond, ha ha, it'll be fine, buddy. I saw this coming.
于是我回复：哈哈，会没事的，伙计。我早料到了。
So, and this is where I say, so did I. That doesn't mean it's going to be fine.
于是我就说：我也是。但这并不意味着事情会好转。
Lots of people feel like their lives are going to be impacted by this election. But this is the person who could deploy these guys, sending them to risk their lives in combat. And on this point, they agreed. One candidate was way more likely to do that.
很多人觉得他们的生活会受到这次选举的影响。但这个人可能会征召他们，派他们去战场冒生命危险。关于这一点，他们达成了一致。其中一位候选人更有可能这么做。
Who's more likely to send us someplace?
谁更有可能派我们去战场？
Hillary.
希拉里。
Hillary Clinton had talked about establishing a no fly zone above Syria. And both men agree, that sounded like a big first step towards war with Syria. Here's Chet.
希拉里·克林顿曾谈到要在叙利亚上空建立禁飞区。两人都同意，那听起来像是战争的第一步。切特说。
Listen, man. I was in Iraq, and I was in Afghanistan. As far as I'm concerned, I don't need to go to another [BLEEP] country to fight another [BLEEP] civil war. Let those [BLEEP] people work it out. It sucks.
听着，伙计。我在伊拉克待过，在阿富汗也待过。就我而言，我不需要再去另一个该死的国家打另一场该死的内战。让那些狗日的自己解决吧。这烂透了。
My question is, it's not that we shouldn't help people, it's at what point, man? At what point do I need to keep helping? At what point do we as Americans have to keep helping the rest of the world?
我的问题不是我们不该帮助别人，而是到什么程度，伙计？我还需要帮助多久？我们作为美国人还要帮全世界帮到什么时候？
I tend to agree with him that I don't want our forces there. But I do not agree with the isolationist policies that Trump is putting forth. I believe that a strong American footprint internationally is important.
我倾向于同意他，我不希望我们的部队出现在那里。但我不同意特朗普提出的孤立主义政策。我认为强大的美国国际影响力很重要。
So that's the big picture. But the small picture is, they both think that under Republican, more money might come into the Army. Maybe their unit will get more money for training, for supplies. But then there's the issue of the recruits. The most recent numbers I could find, in 2008, 65,000 members of the armed services were immigrants. Chet and Tom's unit is really diverse. And Tom's worried that that could change, that fewer people would sign up to the US military as a path to citizenship.
所以这是大图景。但小图景是，他们都认为在共和党领导下，可能会有更多资金注入军队。也许他们的单位会获得更多训练和物资经费。但还有招募新兵的问题。我能找到的最新的数字是，2008年有6.5万名移民在军队服役。切特和汤姆的单位非常多元。汤姆担心这种情况可能会改变，作为获得公民身份途径的招募人数可能会变少。
You're looking at-- what, I don't know how many soldiers I've met that still weren't American citizens.
你看看——我不知道我遇到过多少还没拿到美国公民身份的士兵。
But he's talking a very small minority.
但他谈论的是极少数。
No.
不。
So you're fear is--
所以你的担忧是——
They don't get citizenship because they're--
他们得不到公民身份，因为他们是——
Your fear is that we would get less of those--
你的担忧是我们会招不到这些人——
People that would be invested in America.
那些愿意为美国投入的人。
If Donald Trump is president.
如果唐纳德·特朗普当总统。
Yeah. They're saying, all right, this isn't worth fighting for anymore. They don't care about me. And I have a lot more faith in them to vote for the next president or to participate in the American process than a lot of people that were born in the United States.
是的。他们会说，好吧，这不值得为之战斗了。他们不在乎我。对于参与美国进程，我对他们比对很多土生土长的美国人更有信心。
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
And then, of course, there's the biggest question of all-- the actual, for real, apocalypse. Lots of people this year have questioned whether Donald Trump is too erratic to be trusted with the nuclear codes. Tom's worried. Chet's not.
当然，还有最重要的问题——现实的、真正的世界末日。今年很多人都在质疑唐纳德·特朗普是否过于反复无常，以至于不能信任他掌握核密码。汤姆很担心。切特不担心。
They'll be fine. He's not going to drop nukes on people. I don't know. I think he's incredibly uneducated about it.
会没事的。他不会向人扔核弹的。不知道。我觉得他在这方面非常缺乏常识。
So, here's the thing about the codes that people don't realize. It's not like he has a piece of paper in his pocket. It's like, here are the nuclear codes. It doesn't work that way. How it works is, there's a military officer that walks around with what's called a Football. That officer, he's got more experience than I do. And at the end of the day, if the president goes off the handle and says, nuke these guys because I don't like them, we're taught, in the military, as officers, that we have a moral obligation to refuse orders that are not moral. So if my commander tells me to do that, and it is not moral, I have an obligation to tell him to [BLEEP] off.
关于核密码，人们没意识到的一点是，并不是他口袋里揣着张纸写着“核密码如下”。不是那样运作的。运作方式是有名军官随身带着所谓的“足球”。那名军官比我有经验得多。归根结底，如果总统情绪失控说，去把那帮家伙核平了因为我不喜欢他们，我们军队在军官训练中被教导，我们有道德义务拒绝不道德的命令。所以如果我的指挥官命令我那么做，而那是不道德的，我有义务对他说去死吧。
So you tell him to [BLEEP] off. And then he goes, OK, you're out. So he, as the president, has somebody else [BLEEP] take that Football from you. And then he looks at the guy and goes, are you in, because this guy's fired.
所以你叫他去死。然后他说，好吧，你被解雇了。所以他作为总统，让别人从你手里拿走“足球”。然后他看着那个人说，你干不干，这家伙被解雇了。
Except the guy--
除了那个人——
At the very best, he's fired or he's going to jail.
往好里说，他被解雇了，往坏里说，他要进监狱。
So you're telling me that Army or Navy or Air Force officers of Major or Lieutenant Commander or whatever rank, guys who have been in the military for 15 years, are just going to go ahead, who have children and families, are just going to pull the trigger because Trump decides one day, you know what, [BLEEP] them, I don't like them, nuke them?
所以你在告诉我，陆军、海军或空军的少校、中校或其他军衔的军官，服役15年的家伙们，有孩子和家庭的家伙们，只是因为特朗普某天说，你知道吗，去他妈的他们，我不喜欢他们，去核平他们，他们就会真的去扣动扳机？
You're counting on the moral character of every single one of these individuals.
你在指望每个人的道德品质。
Should we not? Because that's what we're trained to do.
我们难道不应该指望吗？因为这正是我们受训要做的事。
But this comes down to trust, right?
但这归根结底是信任问题，对吧？
It comes down to trust. Absolutely.
归根结底是信任。绝对。
Say I am working for a man that I completely trust. I haven't been informed of the situation at all. And he comes in and he says, this is what's got to be done. More than likely, I would probably do it, right? So I mean, I can't--
假设我为一个我完全信任的人工作。我根本没被告知任何情况。他走过来对我说，必须这么做。很有可能，我会照做的，对吧？所以我没法——
But do you completely trust this man?
但你完全信任这个人吗？
Me? No.
我？不。
Sitting with these guys the night after this divisive, awful election was actually really reassuring. Not the part about possible nuclear obliteration, but it's the way they talk to each other. They disagree on everything, but they like each other so much. They work together great. They get stuff done. So many Trump and Clinton supporters, we just never talk to each other for long enough to realize we might actually get along. In this moment, when nobody seems to be listening to anybody with a different point of view, when each side vilifies the other and thinks the other side is going to destroy this country, it was calming to watch conflict play out in this way that was devoid of rage and judgment and hurt, that had each person continually acknowledging the other person's humanity. After this year, I could use more of that.
在这个令人分裂、可怕的选举后的第二天与这些人坐在一起，其实非常令人宽慰。不是关于可能发生核毁灭的那部分，而是他们交谈的方式。他们在任何事情上都有分歧，但他们非常喜欢对方。他们合作得很出色。他们能成事。太多的特朗普和克林顿支持者，我们从来没有交流足够长的时间，意识到我们可能其实相处得很好。在此时此刻，当没人愿意倾听不同观点，当每一方都将另一方妖魔化，认为另一方会摧毁这个国家时，以这种没有愤怒、没有审判、没有伤害、每个人不断认可对方人性的方式来处理冲突，让人感到平静。经过这一年，我太需要更多这样的时刻了。
Stephanie Foo. Coming up, a Trump supporter explains to us the difference between gloating and simply celebrating. And a foreigner wonders if it's time to leave this country. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·福报道。接下来，一位特朗普的支持者将向我们解释“幸灾乐祸”与“纯粹庆祝”的区别。一位外国人则想知道是否该离开这个国家。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, The Sun Comes Up, people around the country reacting to the news this week in all kinds of ways. The name of today's show came from President Obama's speech the day after the election.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“太阳升起”，全国各地的人们正以各种方式应对这周的新闻。今天节目的名字来自奥巴马总统在选举后的讲话。
Good afternoon, everybody. Yesterday, before votes were tallied, I shot a video that some of you may have seen in which I said to the American people, regardless of which side you were on in the election, regardless of whether your candidate won or lost, the sun would come up in the morning. And that is one bit of prognosticating that actually came true. The sun is up. And I know everybody had a long night.
下午好，各位。昨天，在计票之前，我录了一段视频，你们可能有人看过，我在视频里对美国人民说，不管你在选举中站在哪一边，不管你的候选人是赢是输，明天太阳依然会照常升起。而这正是成真的预测之一。太阳升起来了。我知道大家都度过了漫长的一夜。
We have arrived at Act Six of our show. Act Six, Times Square. So on election night, a young woman named Blair Imani tweeted this around 11:30. Quote, "I'm scared today will be the last day I feel somewhat safe wearing my hijab." I got her on the phone the next day, and she told me that she wrote that after walking through Times Square in New York. Four guys walked past her, probably on their way to the Trump victory party, which wasn't that far away. They were wearing red "Make America Great Again" caps. She had never seen groups of Trump supporters together like that.
我们进入了节目的第六幕。第六幕，时代广场。选举之夜，一位叫布莱尔·伊曼尼的年轻女子在11点半左右发了推特。引用：“我很担心今天会是我戴着希贾布感到安全感的一天。”第二天我通过电话联系了她，她告诉我，这是她在纽约时代广场走过之后写的。四个男人从她身边走过，可能是去特朗普的胜选派对，那儿离这不远。他们戴着红色的“让美国再次伟大”帽子。她从没见过像那样聚集在一起的特朗普支持者。
You know, whenever I see men in red hats-- just because of this election, not before. But you know, because of this election, I kind of tense up and I wait to see what's on their hat. And when I see that it's not "Make America Gay Again" or, you know, a parody of Trump's campaign, I kind of feel a knot in my stomach. And so when I saw four white men walking towards me with "Make America Great Again" hats, I was just kind of feeling the anxiety.
你知道，每当我看到戴红帽子的男人——只是因为这次选举，之前不会。但你知道，因为这次选举，我有点紧张，等待着看帽子上写的是什么。当我看到那不是“让美国再次同性恋”或者特朗普竞选的模仿品时，我胃里会打结。所以当我看到四个白人男人戴着“让美国再次伟大”的帽子向我走来时，我感到的就是那种焦虑。
And were you seriously debating not wearing your hijab.
你当时真的在考虑不戴希贾布了吗？
I always will have my head covered. Today, actually, I went and I bought some hats.
我永远会包着头。其实今天我去买了些帽子。
Wait, so you stopped wearing your hijab.
等等，所以你停止戴希贾布了。
Yeah. And tweeted a picture of myself with, like, hashtag Muslim Girl Camo.
是的。还发了一张自己的照片，标签是“穆斯林女孩迷彩”。
Camo, like camouflage. She's done this in the past sometimes. Like, when she has to fly, she'll wear a hat instead of a hijab on the plane. On election night, there were other people tweeting things, like, quote, "My mom literally texted me, don't wear the hijab, please, and she's the most religious person in our family." And quote, "My mom and sister are actually having the conversation on whether or not they should continue wearing hijab for their own safety."
迷彩，像伪装一样。她过去有时这样做过。比如坐飞机时，她会在飞机上戴帽子代替希贾布。选举之夜，还有其他人发推特说，引用：“我妈妈真的给我发短信，‘求你别戴希贾布’，她是家里最虔诚的人。”引用：“我妈妈和姐姐真的在讨论她们为了自身安全是否应该继续戴希贾布。”
In the days since then, Blair says that she's seeing more and more red hats around New York. Like, Trump supporters are feeling bolder now that he's won in this super-liberal city, which is weird for her. But at the same time, other strangers are being especially nice to her. Before she switched to the hat on Wednesday, an older white woman on the train made a point to sit next to her and smile at her.
从那以后的几天里，布莱尔说她在纽约看到越来越多的红帽子。特朗普支持者在他在这个超级自由派城市获胜后感到更有底气了，这让她觉得很奇怪。但与此同时，其他陌生人对她格外友善。周三换成帽子之前，火车上的一位年长白人女性特意坐到她身边并对她微笑。
There was a couple of situations like that, like when I was in the checkout line getting the hats, the woman noticed that I was getting hats, and she was like, yeah, this is bad.
那种情况有过几次，比如我排队买帽子时，那女人注意到我在买帽子，她说：“是啊，这太糟糕了。”
Do you think it's going to start to feel safer to wear the hijab around New York City?
你认为戴着希贾布在纽约市走动会开始感到更安全吗？
I think-- I'm going to be optimistic in saying that I think yes. So I'm hoping there will be more people, like the old woman today who reached out to me to just kind of make eye contact to smile. And that's really my hope, because that's kind of-- that's what I feel like America should be. And I feel, despite what the polls show, that more people in America are good than are bigoted and awful.
我认为——我会乐观地说，我觉得会。我希望会有更多人，像今天那位接触我并与我眼神交流、微笑的老妇人一样。那真的就是我的希望，因为那正是——我觉得美国应该有的样子。尽管民调显示如此，但我依然认为美国的好人比偏执、可怕的人要多。
Act Seven, Nicholasville, Kentucky. So Donald Trump has been vague and even contradictory about some of the changes that he wants to make once he takes office. But there are some very specific things he's promised over and over. One of our producers, David Kestenbaum, talks to somebody who's life seems like it definitely will be affected.
第七幕，肯塔基州尼古拉斯维尔。唐纳德·特朗普在上任后想做的一些改变，表述一直模糊甚至自相矛盾。但有些具体的承诺他一再重复。我们的制片人戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆采访了一位生活似乎注定会受到影响的人。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, is this Billy?
嘿，是比利吗？
Hold on a second. Billy? Billy?
等等。比利？比利？
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Billy.
嘿，比利。
Hey, what's up.
嘿，什么事。
Billy Webster is 45 years old. He lives in Kentucky, works for Hallmark, setting up the card displays at a local Walmart store. His favorite cards are probably the Star Wars ones.
比利·韦伯斯特45岁。住在肯塔基州，为贺曼工作，在当地的一家沃尔玛商店整理卡片陈列。他最喜欢的卡片可能是《星球大战》的。
Is there a "sorry you lost the election" card?
有没有“对不起你输掉选举”的卡片？
No, I've never seen that, uh-uh.
没有，我没见过，嗯嗯。
Billy voted for Clinton, so he had the usual shock when he saw that Trump was going to win. But he also had this very specific thought watching the TV that night. What is going to happen to my health insurance? He gets his through Obamacare.
比利投了克林顿的票，所以当他看到特朗普要赢时也感到了通常的震惊。但他那天看电视时还有个非常具体的想法：我的医保会怎样？他是通过“奥巴马医改”获得的保险。
What can you do about it?
你能对此做什么？
You hadn't thought about it, but basically, we all decided your health insurance the other day.
你还没想过，但基本上，前几天我们所有人决定了你的医保。
Yeah, basically. Uh-huh.
是的，基本上。嗯哼。
Trump and the Republicans have, of course, promised to repeal Obamacare. And however you feel about Obamacare and how well it's working, there are something like 20 million people currently getting insurance through it. So here, just for the record, is exactly one of those stories. Hallmark, for all its get well cards, does not offer Billy health insurance. The job isn't full time. He says he earned about $12,000 last year. Before that, he was unemployed, and so didn't go to a doctor. Even when stuff happened that really, honestly, you should go to a doctor if it happens to you.
特朗普和共和党人当然承诺要废除“奥巴马医改”。不管你怎么看“奥巴马医改”及其运作效果，目前大约有2000万人通过它获得保险。所以，仅仅作为记录，这就是那些故事中的一个。贺曼尽管生产康复贺卡，却不给比利提供医保。这不是全职工作。他说去年他赚了大约1.2万美元。在那之前，他没工作，也没去看过医生。甚至当那种真的、诚实地如果你遇上就应该看医生的情况发生时。
Thanksgiving Day, you know, I had a big meal at Thanksgiving. And all of sudden, I just got this rush of not feeling good, like my vision started blurring, and my feet tingled and hurt really bad. And I don't know, I lost my hearing. I started having a little ringing in my years. And just, I don't know, kind of like an out-of-body experience.
感恩节那天，你知道，我吃了顿大餐。突然间，我感到一阵不适，像视觉开始模糊，脚趾发麻并剧痛。我不知道，我听力丧失了。耳朵开始有点耳鸣。就像某种灵魂出窍的体验。
Didn't your parents or friends say, you should go to a doctor?
你的父母或朋友没说你应该去看医生吗？
Oh, they always tell you that, yeah. But I couldn't afford it. So yeah, they always tell you that when you're sick and you don't feel good. Yeah,   go to the doctor. Well, you gonna pay for it?
哦，他们总是那样说。但我付不起。所以是的，当你病得难受时，他们总是说“看医生”。那你给我付钱吗？
When Obamacare came along, Billy qualified for insurance under the Medicaid expansion part of it. It cost him about $50 a month. And he finally went to a doctor who did a simple blood test and was like, yeah, you got diabetes.
当“奥巴马医改”出现时，比利通过其中的医疗补助扩大部分获得了保险。每月大约50美元。他终于去看了医生，医生做了个简单的验血，然后说：“是的，你有糖尿病。”
I was ecstatic. I mean--
我当时狂喜。我是说——
You were ecstatic to be diagnosed with diabetes?
你被诊断出糖尿病居然狂喜？
No, I'm ecstatic to know what I had.
不，我狂喜是因为我知道了我得了什么病。
The doctor prescribed some pills, and pretty quickly, Billy's blood sugar levels went back into the normal range.
医生开了些药，很快比利的血糖水平恢复到了正常范围。
I mean, I felt so much better after that. So it probably saved my life, you know. With diabetes, you can lose your eyesight, lose your limbs.
我是说，之后我感觉好多了。所以它可能救了我的命，你知道。得了糖尿病，你可能会失明、失去四肢。
Trump was never very specific about what he would replace Obamacare with. Billy says, to be honest, losing health insurance would not be the end of the world. It's not like he has cancer, doesn't need heart surgery, though that is certainly the case for some other people on Obamacare. Billy told me he'd have to pay for the diabetes medication himself, which would be a strain, but he said he'd just have to find a way. And if something really went wrong, he's not just going to sit at home and die.
特朗普从未具体说明他会用什么取代“奥巴马医改”。比利说，老实说，失去医保也不是世界末日。他也没得癌症，不需要心脏手术，尽管这对比利医改下其他一些人来说确实是那样。比利告诉我他得自己掏钱买糖尿病药物，那会是个负担，但他说明天只能想办法。如果真的出了大事，他也不会只是坐在家里等死。
You know, I'll go to the emergency room. You know, and then the state can pay for it, or whoever else is the people that complain about people like me or whatever that has benefited from this, then they can just pay for it out of their taxes. You know, the people of the state of Kentucky can pay for those $1,000 emergency room bills. I'll never pay. So-- I mean, I'd try to pay them, but you know, I was just being sarcastic.
你知道，我会去急诊室。然后由州政府或者其他那些抱怨像我这样从这项政策中受益的人来付账，他们可以从税收里付。你知道，肯塔基州的人民可以为那些1000美元的急诊室账单买单。我永远不会付。所以——我是说，我会试着付，但你知道，我刚才是在讽刺。
Going to the emergency room with no money, that's basically the system we had before Obamacare. I asked Billy if he thought Trump and the Republicans might replace Obamacare with something better. Maybe, he said. I should just give the guy a chance.
没钱去急诊室，那基本上就是“奥巴马医改”之前的制度。我问比利他是否认为特朗普和共和党可能会用更好的方案取代“奥巴马医改”。也许吧，他说。我应该给那个人一个机会。
David Kestenbaum.
戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆报道。
Act Eight, Greenville, South Carolina. So, all this year, we've been talking to Trump voters, as their chances went from laughable to striking distance to victory. One guy who was all the way for Trump back in February was Barry Chisholm. His son was too. His son's Dave. Our producer, Zoe Chace, met them back then. They used to call up their local talk show host on the radio and crow about how great Donald Trump was. They were underdogs back then. So we checked back in this week to see how the week was going for them.
第八幕，南卡罗来纳州格林维尔。今年这一整年，我们一直在与特朗普的支持者交谈，他们的胜率从可笑到进入射程，再到最终胜利。早在二月份就全力支持特朗普的一个人是巴里·奇瑟姆。他的儿子也是。他儿子叫戴夫。我们的制片人佐伊·切斯那时采访了他们。他们过去常给当地电台脱口秀主持人打电话，吹嘘唐纳德·特朗普有多棒。那时他们还是不被看好的一方。所以我们这周回访了他们，看看这一周对他们来说怎么样。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Barry. It's Zoe.
嘿，巴里。我是佐伊。
What's going on? Are you being safe up there or what?
什么事？你在那儿还安全吗，或者怎么样？
I'm safe.
我很安全。
Walking around the streets of New York? Good grief. Doesn't seem like they're too happy still, huh?
走在纽约街头？天哪。看起来他们还不太高兴，是吧？
Um, yeah. I do think a lot of people are upset.
嗯，是的。我确实认为很多人很沮丧。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, we're pretty safe here in the South.
嗯哼。是的，我们在南方这里挺安全的。
Yeah, I'm wearing my Trump hat today. I'm good to go. I'm getting a lot of high-fives.
是啊，我今天戴着我的特朗普帽子。我准备好了。我得到了很多击掌。
You're getting a lot of high-fives in your Trump hat?
你戴着特朗普帽子得到了很多击掌？
We're deep in the deplorable country.
我们深处“可悲者”之国。
Are you guys excited?
你们兴奋吗？
Yeah, but only to the point of celebration. Not like we get satisfaction-- there's a difference between celebrating and gloating. Gloating is you're happy that someone else is sad. You're happy that someone else is stressed. That is not where our happiness or celebratory comes from. It's from the fact that we defended this campaign and we wanted it. And our guy won. It doesn't go past that. I think it's a little ridiculous. I think people are overboard with being that upset, because we weren't even that upset with Obama.
是的，但仅限于庆祝。不像我们能得到满足感——庆祝和幸灾乐祸之间是有区别的。幸灾乐祸是你因为别人的悲伤而高兴。你因为别人感到压力而高兴。我们并不是那样获得快乐或进行庆祝的。这是因为我们捍卫了这场竞选，并且我们想要它。我们的人赢了。仅此而已。我觉得有点荒谬。我觉得人们对于如此沮丧简直过头了，因为奥巴马当选时我们甚至没那么沮丧。
Yeah, we didn't see-- did you remember all the deplorables out on the street when Obama got elected, punching all the Obama voters. You remember that, right?
是啊，我们没看到——你记得奥巴马当选时街上有所有那些“可悲者”在殴打奥巴马支持者吗？你记得吗？
No.
不。
No, you don't.
不，你不记得。
That's why all these people that are upset-- they don't realize the good that's going to come. They're going to benefit. I think eventually they're going to come around. Honestly, my thing is-- this is where I'll be going forward-- we don't want to be rubbing it in people's faces. I want to show people that this is going to be better. "Make America Great Again" includes all the citizens that are in this country. So when the economy goes, everybody goes up.
这就是为什么所有这些人如此沮丧——他们没有意识到即将到来的好处。他们会受益的。我认为最终他们会转过弯来的。老实说，我接下来会怎么做——我们不想把这件事抹在别人的脸上。我想向人们展示，未来会变得更好。“让美国再次伟大”包括这个国家的所有公民。所以当经济好转，每个人都会受益。
You just think the economy is just going to go gangbusters now?
你只是认为经济现在会突飞猛进吗？
If you do one thing-- well, you get the regulations off, you do the pipeline, you let them drill for oil, you bring the coal back, and Hillary's happy to tell people she's going to put them out of a job. That's all these people have their whole lives in generations. They don't have the luxury of going out there and using their political position to use the State Department to make herself a multimillionaire. These people have to work every day for a living.
如果你做一件事——嗯，你解除监管，你修建输油管道，你让他们钻探石油，你带回煤炭，而希拉里很乐意告诉人们她要让他们失业。这就是这些人世世代代所拥有的全部。他们没有那种利用政治地位通过国务院把自己变成千万富翁的奢侈。这些人必须每天工作为生。
It sounds like you're still mad at Hillary.
听起来你还在对希拉里生气。
Well, I'm mad at the way-- no, I'm not mad at Hillary. I mean, you know, it's a difference of opinion. I mean, it's a difference of ideology. And then yeah, well, wouldn't you be mad if people were calling you racist and xenophobe? I mean, good grief.
嗯，我对那种方式生气——不，我不是对希拉里生气。我是说，你知道，这是意见分歧。我是说，这是意识形态的分歧。那好，如果人们一直称你为种族主义者和仇外者，你难道不会生气吗？我是说，天哪。
Well, so, what are you so happy about? Like, what's going to happen now?
所以，你到底在高兴什么？比如，现在会发生什么？
Good grief, how could you not be? Look it, we've had a lawless country. The immigration law is a mockery to people who obey the law. You have a president doing executive orders. If you do one thing, well, you get the regulations off, you do the pipeline, and then the repatriation-- there's $2 trillion. They're not going to bring it back and pay 35%. These are business people. They're not stupid. They're not going to hand their money over to a bunch of dopey politicians.
天哪，你怎么可能不高兴？看哪，我们一直有一个无法无天的国家。移民法对遵守法律的人来说是个笑话。你有一个用行政令治理国家的总统。如果你做一件事，嗯，你解除监管，你搞定输油管道，然后遣返——那里有2万亿美元。他们不会带回来并缴纳35%的税。这些是生意人。他们不傻。他们不会把钱交给一群笨拙的政客。
See?
看吧？
So, if they do--
所以，如果他们做——
Barry, you still sound mad. I'm saying, you still--
巴里，你听起来还是很生气。我说，你还是——
No, I'm excited.
不，我很兴奋。
OK, that's your excited. OK.
好吧，那就是你兴奋的样子。好吧。
Because we have the opportunity to do this now.
因为我们现在有机会做这件事了。
Are you nervous he's going to disappoint you now? He's not going to be as good as you thought?
你紧张他现在会让你失望吗？他不会像你预想的那么好？
Do I worry about, can he stick to his first principles and the things that he talked about? Of course I do. I didn't say that-- this guy is not like a saviour. This guy is not going to be the answer to all of the problems that this country faces. But can he do some good things? I think so.
我担心他能否坚持他的基本原则和他谈论的事情吗？我当然担心。我没说——这个家伙不是什么救世主。这个家伙不会成为这个国家面临的所有问题的答案。但他能做些好事吗？我想可以。
Zoe Chace.
佐伊·切斯报道。
Act Nine, Salt Lake City. Emily Ellsworth is a lifelong Republican. Grew up Mormon in one of the most reliably Republican states in the country. Culturally, being Mormon is pretty much synonymous with being Republican. But like lots of Mormons, Emily found Donald Trump unacceptable. 175,000 Utahans voted for third-party candidate Evan McMullin. Lots more did not vote at all.
第九幕，盐湖城。艾米丽·埃尔斯沃斯是终身的共和党人。在全国最坚定的共和党州之一摩门教环境中长大。从文化上讲，摩门教几乎等同于共和党。但像许多摩门教徒一样，艾米丽发现唐纳德·特朗普是不可接受的。17.5万犹他州人投票给了第三方候选人埃文·麦克马林。还有更多人根本没投票。
Emily decided she was going to vote for Hillary Clinton after she  watched the Democratic Convention. She liked her. She liked the message she was sending to women. Because of where she lived, Emily's experience before the election was different from most Clinton supporters. And her experience after it this week has also been. For starters, if your world is Mormon and you live in Utah, there are consequences if you support Clinton. Elna Baker explains.
艾米丽在看了民主党全国代表大会后决定投票给希拉里·克林顿。她喜欢她。她喜欢她向女性传递的信息。由于居住地点的关系，艾米丽在选举前的经历与大多数希拉里支持者不同。她本周选举后的经历也同样不同。首先，如果你的世界是摩门教且你住在犹他州，支持克林顿是有后果的。埃尔娜·贝克解释。
Even before Donald Trump won, Emily paid a price for publicly supporting Hillary Clinton. Her former coworkers stopped calling and texting. She and her younger sister are no longer on speaking terms because of their political and ideological differences. Emily wasn't even invited to her wedding ceremony. It was incredibly lonely.
甚至在唐纳德·特朗普获胜之前，艾米丽就因为公开支持希拉里·克林顿付出了代价。她以前的同事不再给她打电话或发短信。她和妹妹因为政治和意识形态差异不再说话。艾米丽甚至没被邀请参加妹妹的婚礼。这极其孤独。
I didn't think I was being all that radical. I feel that I am standing alone out there, and I don't know who has my back. You feel like you're just very exposed, being out in a field or on an island.
我不认为我当时表现得那么激进。我觉得我在外面孤军奋战，不知道谁支持我。你感觉就像置身于田野中或荒岛上，非常暴露。
Emily's not just a casual Republican. Her father was a precinct chair in Utah. And growing up, he would hold meetings in her living room. To her, the Republican Party feels like home-- literally, as in, it feels like the voices coming from the living room. Her dad would take her to election parties and Republican state conventions. As a little girl, she'd wanted to be president. But her mother discouraged her. But still, she figured she'd run for some office one day.
艾米丽不仅仅是个随意的共和党人。她父亲是犹他州的选区主席。从小到大，他会在她客厅里举行会议。对她来说，共和党感觉就像家——字面上，感觉就像来自客厅的声音。她爸爸会带她去选举派对和共和党州代表大会。小时候，她想成为总统。但她母亲劝阻了她。不过，她还是觉得有一天会竞选公职。
As an adult, she worked for two years for Republican Congressman Chris Stewart and four years for Jason Chaffetz, who was one of the most outspoken Republicans about the Benghazi attack. When Emily decided on Hillary Clinton, she went bigly. She wrote an op-ed entitled "Republican Women Should Join Me in Voting for Hillary." She started the Utah chapter of Republican Women for Hillary, she worked the phones for the Clinton campaign, she did interviews on TV. It wasn't the first time she took a stand like this.
成年后，她为共和党国会议员克里斯·斯图尔特工作了两年，为杰森·查菲茨工作了四年，后者是共和党对班加西袭击最直言不讳的人之一。当艾米丽决定支持希拉里·克林顿时，她做出了重大行动。她写了一篇题为《共和党女性应该和我一起投票支持希拉里》的专栏文章。她发起了犹他州“共和党女性支持希拉里”分会，她为希拉里竞选团队拨打电话，她接受电视采访。这不是她第一次采取这样的立场。
Two years earlier, Emily had been involved in a movement to get Mormon women more authority in the Church. When Mormon boys turn 12, they're given the power to act in the name of God and to speak on his behalf. Girls at 12 get a trinket necklace. Women can't be priests, elders, bishops, stake president, patriarchs, Quorum of the Seventy, Apostles, Prophets. And for the rest of their lives, it's not that women are second-class citizens. It's that their connection to God can be vetoed by a man at any time. Like, if Hermione had to run all her spells past Harry Potter and wasn't allowed to have a wand, she would be pissed.
两年前，艾米丽参与了一项运动，旨在让摩门教女性在教会中获得更多权力。当摩门教男孩12岁时，他们被赋予以神之名行事并代神发言的权力。女孩在12岁时得到一条首饰项链。女性不能成为祭司、长老、主教、支联会会长、族长、七十员、使徒、先知。而在她们的余生中，女性并不是二等公民。而是她们与神的联系随时可能被一名男性否决。就像，如果赫敏必须把所有咒语先跑过哈利·波特并被禁止拥有魔杖，她会气疯的。
Emily looked at Hillary Clinton and thought, if a woman were president, it would be hard for the Mormon Church to continue saying a woman can't have authority. It'd send a message to little girls, and over time, maybe more women would demand leadership positions.
艾米丽看着希拉里·克林顿心想，如果一位女性担任总统，摩门教教会继续声称女性不能拥有权力将变得困难。这会向小女孩传递一个信息，随着时间推移，也许会有更多女性要求担任领导职务。
Emily has a six-year-old daughter named Abigail. The same way Emily was ushered into politics as a little girl, she ushered Abigail in. They talked about Hillary Clinton a lot. She used Hillary to teach Abigail a lesson she hadn't been taught, that Abigail could become president one day. Then on Tuesday Hillary Clinton lost to Donald Trump, and it was devastating. I talked Emily on Wednesday.
艾米丽有个6岁的女儿叫阿比盖尔。就像艾米丽小时候被领进政治一样，她也领着阿比盖尔。她们谈论了很多希拉里·克林顿。她用希拉里给阿比盖尔上一课，那是她小时候没上过的一课，即阿比盖尔有一天可以成为总统。然后在周二，希拉里·克林顿输给了唐纳德·特朗普，这太令人毁灭了。我周三采访了艾米丽。
I did not even send my daughter to school today. My daughter Abigail told me-- she's in first grade-- that yesterday they had a mock election, and she was the only one in her class who voted for Hillary Clinton, and that her friends said-- you know, she said that they tried to get her to vote for Donald Trump. And she just said, I wasn't going to do it. They weren't going to bully me into voting for anybody that I didn't want to. And she took great pride in that.
我今天甚至没送女儿上学。我女儿阿比盖尔告诉我——她上一年级——昨天她们班搞了场模拟选举，她是班里唯一投给希拉里·克林顿的人，她的朋友说——你知道，她说他们试图让她投唐纳德·特朗普。她只是说，我才不投呢。他们休想欺凌我投票给任何我不想投的人。她为此感到非常自豪。
I was afraid of what her classmates were going to say to her about being a Hillary voter and a Hillary supporter. I mean, I wish I could rewind time. If I had been less excited about it and hadn't talked it up as much, then she wouldn't be this disappointed. And I feel like I wanted her so badly to believe that she could do anything she wanted. And now there's a part of her that does not believe that anymore.
我很担心她的同学会因为她是希拉里的投票者和支持者而对她说些什么。我是说，我真希望能时光倒流。如果我没那么兴奋，没那么大肆宣传，她就不会这么失望了。我觉得我太渴望让她相信她可以做任何她想做的事了。而现在她的一部分不再相信这一点了。
She's been painting pictures and drawing things about being president and has said that she wants to be a female president, that she was going to be next. And today she said, if Hillary Clinton can't win, I don't think I can win either. And I don't know what to tell her, because I want to say, no, you can be anything you want. But yesterday showed us that maybe that is just not the reality yet.
她一直在画画，画关于成为总统的事情，并说她想成为女总统，她要成为下一个。而今天她说：“如果希拉里·克林顿都赢不了，我觉得我也赢不了。”我不知道该对她说什么，因为我想说，不，你可以成为任何你想成为的人。但昨天向我们展示了也许那还不是现实。
Let's be clear. Emily voted for Hillary Clinton, but she's not a Democrat. She's a committed Republican, and all her hopes for the country are with the GOP. But this year, she watched her old boss Jason Chaffetz and other senior Utah Republicans, Mormons, un-endorse Donald Trump after the Access Hollywood tape, and then, three weeks later, re-endorse him. It was surreal, she said, to hear them describe it as this moral choice.
让我们明确一点。艾米丽投票给希拉里·克林顿，但她不是民主党人。她是坚定的共和党人，对国家的所有希望都寄托在共和党身上。但今年，她在《走进好莱坞》的录音带曝光后，看着她的前老板杰森·查菲茨和其他犹他州资深共和党人、摩门教徒不再背书唐纳德·特朗普，然后在三周后又重新背书。她说，听到他们将其描述为一种道德选择真是超现实。
It felt incredibly personal because these were people I had worked with and people who had told me that they really didn't like Trump but here they were just saying, but you've got to go out and vote for him.
这感觉极其个人化，因为这些人是我曾一起工作过的人，他们曾告诉我他们真的不喜欢特朗普，但现在他们在这里说，但你必须去投票支持他。
It felt like a betrayal, of her, of women. Which is why she'd hoped Donald Trump would lose and Hillary Clinton would win.
这感觉像是一种背叛，对她，对女性的背叛。这就是为什么她希望唐纳德·特朗普输掉，而希拉里·克林顿获胜。
In my mind, this would have been a true wake-up call that we needed to expand who we were reaching and we needed to let go of some of these ideas that were unpopular with women and minorities and immigrants.
在我心目中，这将是一个真正的警钟，提醒我们有必要扩大我们接触的对象，有必要放弃一些在女性、少数族裔和移民中不受欢迎的观点。
And now that that didn't happen, what does it mean for the Republican Party?
而现在那没发生，这对共和党意味着什么？
They got their pass. And I think that sends a signal to the Republican Party that Donald Trump has it right. It makes me feel that there's not a place for me in a position of leadership in my church, in my party, or in the presidency. I'm not allowed to have the priesthood, I'm not allowed to have the presidency. And it just feels like another slap in the face, that there are certain things that women are just not allowed to have.
他们得到了通过。我认为这向共和党传递了一个信号，即唐纳德·特朗普做得对。这让我觉得无论是在我的教会、我的政党，还是在总统职位上，都没有我的领导位置。我不被允许拥有祭司职位，我不被允许拥有总统职位。这感觉像又一记耳光，有些东西就是不被允许女性拥有。
Emily's in a real predicament now. She was so vocal about supporting Hillary Clinton. If she hadn't been, she said, or if Clinton had won and Trump had lost, in four years, she could have run for something. Not president, of course. Something local, something small, a place to start. Now, that's not going to happen.
艾米丽现在处境艰难。她对支持希拉里·克林顿表现得非常直言不讳。她说，如果她没那么做，或者如果克林顿赢了而特朗普输了，四年后她本可以竞选点什么。当然不是总统。竞选一些地方公职，一些小公职，一个开始的地方。现在，那不会发生了。
Elna Baker.
埃尔娜·贝克报道。
Act 10, New York. President-Elect Donald Trump has made it clear that he's going to be tough on both legal and illegal immigrants. That means many immigrants in this country got scared when he won. Zoe Chace sat in the day after the election with some immigration lawyers who were getting nervous calls from their clients.
第10幕，纽约。当选总统唐纳德·特朗普已经明确表示，他会对合法和非法移民都采取强硬态度。这意味着这个国家的许多移民在他获胜时感到害怕。佐伊·切斯在选举后的一天与一些感到紧张的移民律师待在一起，他们接到了客户不安的电话。
There are two types of worries in this world. One's based on a real threat, and one's based on a feeling. And this week immigration lawyers are sorting through both of those. This is an email that Cheryl David, a longtime immigration lawyer in New York, woke up to this morning.
这世上有两种担忧。一种基于真实威胁，一种基于感觉。这周移民律师正在理清这两者。这是一封谢丽尔·戴维——纽约一位资深移民律师——今早醒来看到的邮件。
"Hi, Cheryl. I'm in total shock for the election result. I'm literally in disbelief. I slept three hours total."
“嘿，谢丽尔。我对选举结果感到震惊。我简直不敢相信。我总共只睡了三个小时。”
She's reading this to me and my friend Lindsey Gauzza who's also her associate. I spent the day after the election at their office. The email is about one of their clients.
她正在把这封邮件念给我和我的朋友林赛·高扎听，后者也是她的同事。我在选举后的一天在她们办公室待了一整天。这封邮件是关于她们的一位客户的。
"Is it premature to ask for asylum in Canada? I'm worried that my own green card will be revoked, as I come from a country that has Syrian refugees. Please let me know your thoughts. I'm in total political disarray. Grazie."
“现在申请加拿大庇护是否操之过急？我担心我自己的绿卡会被撤销，因为我来自一个有叙利亚难民的国家。请告诉我你的想法。我处于彻底的政治混乱中。谢谢。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Revoke my green card because I'm from a country that has Syrian refugees?
“撤销我的绿卡因为我来自一个有叙利亚难民的国家？”
Refugees.
难民。
Like, that's insane on one hand. On the other hand, it's like, oh, it makes sense. We do hate Syrian refugees apparently in this country.
一方面，这太疯狂了。另一方面，这又说得通。显然，在这个国家我们确实讨厌叙利亚难民。
During the election, President-elect Trump said a couple things about immigrants that have freaked out these lawyers and their clients. Keep out Muslim refugees, build a wall-- they obviously don't know if Trump is going to do any of that as president or how that will change their jobs. And they hadn't seriously considered that Trump's views on immigration would become the law-- like, really not. Especially lately, they've been super-excited about Hillary Clinton, Cheryl the most. She's the boss. This is an all-lady office. No men work here. The day I was there, they'd watched Hillary Clinton's concession speech in the dark in Cheryl's office. Sobbing, they said.
在竞选中，当选总统特朗普关于移民说了一些话，吓坏了这些律师和她们的客户。禁止穆斯林难民入境，建一堵墙——她们显然不知道特朗普作为总统会做其中任何一件，也不知道这会如何改变她们的工作。她们之前并没有认真考虑过特朗普的移民观会成为法律——真的没想过。尤其是最近，她们对希拉里·克林顿超级兴奋，谢丽尔最甚。她是老板。这是一个全女性办公室。没有男人在这里工作。我去的那天，她们在黑暗中在谢丽尔办公室看了希拉里·克林顿的败选演说。她们说哭得稀里哗啦。
We spend a lot of time together. We talk about this stuff all day long. We've been talking about the election--
我们在一起花了很多时间。我们整天都在谈论这些事情。我们一直在谈论选举——
For two years.
两年了。
For two years, every single day. And yesterday we felt so positive. We were talking about a matriarchy.
两年了，每天都是。昨天我们感觉太积极了。我们在谈论母权社会。
No, it didn't even-- it didn't even enter my mind yesterday that she would lose. It's devastating.
不，甚至——昨天我都没想过她会输。这太毁灭了。
The thing that feels like the legit worry is that all of President Obama's executive orders will be repealed on day one. Trump said over and over he would do this. And that will affect a lot of their immigration cases. For instance, DACA-- this is a status for young adults who came here as children illegally, most of them brought by their parents, the Dream Act kids. DACA lets them stay in the country and work. It's renewable every two years. Unless it isn't anymore. Cheryl reads me another email they got early that morning.
感觉像是真正担忧的是，奥巴马总统的所有行政令将在第一天被废除。特朗普一再表示会这样做。那将影响许多移民案件。例如，DACA——这是针对非法入境的年轻成年人的身份，大多数是父母带进来的，也就是“梦想生”计划。DACA让他们能留在国内工作。每两年更新一次。除非它不再存在。谢丽尔给我读了那天早上早些时候收到的另一封邮件。
"Hi, Andrea or Cheryl. I'm sure you're getting flooded with emails about Trump and his position on deporting DACA members. What should I expect to happen with my application in future?"
“嘿，安德里亚或谢丽尔。我相信你们一定收到了关于特朗普及其驱逐DACA成员立场的邮件。我的申请未来会发生什么？”
They don't know the answer. It feels too soon to have the question. But it doesn't look good for this client.
她们不知道答案。感觉问题来得太快了。但这对比这位客户来说看起来不妙。
Really, the ones that I am a little concerned-- I'm concerned about the DACA, because I think he will take the DACA. I think they're going to end the DACA program. I don't think he'll take it away from the people who have it, but they won't be allowed to renew it because it's an executive order. So I think executive orders are over. And I am pretty straight with clients. I don't sugarcoat.
真的，让我有点担心的是——我担心DACA，因为我认为他会取消DACA。我认为他们要终止DACA项目。我不认为他会从已经拥有它的人那里夺走，但他们将不被允许续签，因为那是一项行政令。所以我认为行政令完了。我对客户非常直接。我不粉饰。
So, what did you say?
所以，你怎么说？
I said, I think that they're going to take it away. You know, why sugarcoat it?
我说，我认为他们会取消它。你知道，为什么要粉饰呢？
Hello?
喂？
Hello? How's life?
喂？生活怎么样？
Um, OK. I'm worried about Trump, you know, his policies.
嗯，还可以。我很担心特朗普，你知道，他的政策。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
He's Jamaican. He's got a green card. Lots of the clients here are in this country legally. They have a green card or a valid visa. But they've committed crimes that make them deportable. This guy's like that. Obviously these are people Donald Trump has said he wants to deport. President Obama has also targeted them. These lawyers think even under President Trump, this guy has a pretty good case to stay here.
他是牙买加人。他有绿卡。这里很多客户是合法居留在这个国家的。他们有绿卡或有效签证。但他们犯了罪，使他们可以被驱逐。这个家伙就是这样。显然这些人是唐纳德·特朗普说想要驱逐的。奥巴马总统也把他们作为目标。这些律师认为即使在特朗普总统领导下，这个家伙留在美国的理由也很充分。
Yeah. I mean, first of all, you're already in a situation where immigration has already come to-- you have come to their attention. So for your purposes, the worst has already happened, and we're taking care of it. And it's not going to get worse for you right now. I mean, you're eligible for relief. There's been no talk of him making it worse for people who are already green card holders.
是的。我的意思是，首先，你已经处于一种移民局已经——你已经引起他们注意的情况。所以对于你的目的，最糟糕的事情已经发生了，我们正在处理它。这对你来说现在不会变得更糟。我的意思是，你有资格获得救济。没有迹象表明他会让已经持有绿卡的人情况变糟。
This is an example of the other kind of call they've been getting all day. Just generalized anxiety. No particular reason. Just has my case changed now? Is everything different?
这是她们整天收到的另一种电话的例子。只是普遍的焦虑。没有特殊原因。我的案子现在变了吗？一切都不同了吗？
I mean, are things going to change? I think so. But not for you, I hope. There's no sign that it will change for you.
我的意思是，事情会改变吗？我想会。但不是针对你，我希望。没有迹象表明它会为你改变。
Oh, OK. I appreciate it. I just wanted a heads-up, you know.
哦，好吧。我感激。我只是想要个提醒，你知道。
Yeah, I know. I don't blame you. We're all panicking.
是啊，我知道。我不怪你。我们都在恐慌。
Yeah, I know, you know?
是啊，我知道，你知道吗？
Lin says she knows how it is under President Obama. Like, she knows how to react and advise her clients. She knows when they're safe and when they are not.
林说她知道奥巴马总统领导下的情况。就像，她知道如何反应和建议她的客户。她知道他们何时安全，何时不安全。
And I've felt pretty confident in the last five years to say, I can take you even though you have a deportation order. You have a path forward. We can get rid of it. We can get to a green card. And come with me, I will walk you into this office. We will have an interview with the government. They will not arrest you. That maybe isn't true anymore. And we won't know until they start arresting people. You know, they're not going to put out a statement saying--
过去五年我感到非常有信心说，即使你有驱逐令，我也能处理。你还有前进的道路。我们可以摆脱它。我们可以获得绿卡。跟我来，我会带你走进这个办公室。我们会和政府面试。他们不会逮捕你。那也许不再是真的了。而我们直到他们开始逮捕人之前都不会知道。你知道，他们不会发表声明说——
Crackdown looks like this.
打击看起来是这样的。
Exactly, exactly. They're just going to start doing it around-- and it's going to be different all over the country. So you're going to have advocates in San Francisco saying, it's happening like this. Atlanta is going to be having a different scenario. New York, who knows? So it just feels really anxiety-inducing for me, and I'm not even the person who is being marched into the government's offices. It's not my life.
没错，没错。他们只是会开始在各地做这件事——而且全国各地都会不同。所以你在旧金山会有倡导者说，情况正在发生。亚特兰大会有不同的场景。纽约，谁知道呢？所以这让我感到非常焦虑，而我甚至不是那个被带进政府办公室的人。那不是我的生活。
We were talking about this a little bit before, but I don't-- it's a terrible feeling to not know how to advise your clients when they call. Usually it's like, if I don't know the answer, I can go to Cheryl. And Cheryl almost always knows the answer. And we can figure it out. We can think about the law. We can look at cases. This, it's like, we don't know. We have lists of clients who are waiting for us to do certain applications we've been preparing to file that now we're not sure if we can. And we're not going to know the answer for a while. I mean, there's--
我们之前聊过一点，但我不想——当客户打电话来时不知道如何建议他们，这是一种糟糕的感觉。通常是这样，如果我不知道答案，我可以去找谢丽尔。而谢丽尔几乎总是知道答案。我们可以弄明白。我们可以思考法律。我们可以看案例。这次，就像，我们不知道。我们有一份客户名单，等着我们做他们准备提交的某些申请，现在我们不确定是否可以了。而我们有一段时间都不会知道答案。我是说，有——
And I think we don't know the answer because I don't think he knows what he wants to do, frankly. I think as a president he doesn't know what he wants to do. I mean, I guess he could build his wall and he'll be busy building the wall and maybe forget about other parts of immigration. And once the wall is built, he'll look at the policies, so we might be safe. Brick by brick.
而且我认为我们不知道答案是因为我不认为他知道自己想做什么，坦率地说。我认为作为总统，他不知道自己想做什么。我是说，我想他可能会建他的墙，他会忙于建墙，也许会忘记移民的其他部分。墙建好后，他会再看政策，所以我们也许是安全的。一块砖一块砖地来。
A lot of immigration lawyers around the country are worried and confused, and they got in touch with each other this week. Conference calls, webinars, Facebook posts-- they're in uncharted territory, lots of them, and they don't know what to think. Once they have the new rules, they'll get a new strategy. It's the not knowing that's painful for lawyers.
全国各地的许多移民律师都很担心和困惑，这周她们互相联系。电话会议、网络研讨会、Facebook帖子——她们处于未知领域，很多人都是，她们不知道该想什么。一旦有了新规则，她们会有新策略。正是这种“不知道”让律师感到痛苦。
Zoe Chace.
佐伊·切斯报道。
Act 11, Toledo, Ohio. So, the youngest person on our production staff is Emmanuel-- Emmanuel Dzotsi. He's 23, grew up in Toledo, Ohio. But he's British. His dad's company would move their family around a lot. His dad worked in marketing. And so they've lived in England and in Belgium and here in the United States, in Ohio. And late on election night, just before midnight Eastern time, Emanuel was the last person at the office. And he got on the phone to his mom, back home in Ohio, and recorded the conversation.
第11幕，俄亥俄州托莱多。那么，我们制作团队里最年轻的人是伊曼纽尔——伊曼纽尔·佐齐。他23岁，在俄亥俄州托莱多长大。但他是个英国人。他父亲的公司会经常带他们一家搬家。他父亲从事市场营销工作。所以他们住在英格兰、比利时和美国，在俄亥俄州。在选举之夜深夜，美东时间午夜前，伊曼纽尔是办公室最后一个人。他打电话给在俄亥俄州老家的妈妈，录下了这段谈话。
I called my mom, because after watching America vote this anti-immigrant candidate into the presidency, I had this vague panic, that all of a sudden I wasn't welcome here anymore. We're the only black family in our neighborhood in Toledo. We used to be the only Brits too. But somehow our suburb has more of those than other black people.
我给妈妈打电话，因为在看着美国把这位反移民候选人选进总统职位后，我有一种模糊的恐慌，觉得突然间我不再受欢迎了。我们是托莱多街区唯一的黑人家庭。我们也曾经是唯一的英国人。但不知何故我们的郊区比其他黑人家庭更多那些人。
And I know this election has been hard on my mom. Our friends and our neighbors tell her of their anti-immigrant views. They forget she's an immigrant because she's been here so long. And they forget she's black because she's English. And they say all kinds of things about Black Lives Matter or the Obamas.
我知道这次选举对我妈妈来说很难。我们的朋友和邻居告诉她他们的反移民观点。他们忘了她是移民因为她在这待了太久。他们忘了她是黑人因为她是英国人。他们对“黑人的命也是命”或奥巴马说了各种各样的话。
Come election time in this country, people who otherwise seem quite normal or rational people suddenly say the most outlandish and hurtful things. And they don't even seem to realize that the things that they are saying are extremely hurtful and offensive to me.
到了这个国家的选举时间，那些平时看起来很正常或理性的普通人突然说出最离谱和伤人的话。他们甚至似乎没意识到他们所说的内容对我来说极其伤人且冒犯。
[SIGHS] OK, Mommy. I don't know.
[叹气] 好吧，妈咪。我不知道。
You know, you just feel that the general populace clearly don't want you here. After all, when Donald Trump started denouncing the H-B1 visa as well, that's the visa under which we came here.
你知道，你只是觉得大众显然不想要你待在这里。毕竟，当唐纳德·特朗普也开始谴责H-1B签证时，那可是我们来这里的签证。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. You know?
是啊。你知道吗？
I didn't realize until she said it, right then. That's us. Like, that exact thing is us, the H-1B visa. I'd seen him talk about that.
直到她说出来我才意识到，就在那一刻。那是我们。就像，那件事确切地指的就是我们，H-1B签证。我看到他谈论过那个。
You know, we do have our green card. We are legally here as permanent residents. The only thing is, is that our green cards come up for renewal in a year or two. So we have to decide. Either we decide to plunge all in and go for citizenship, or we renew. But then renewal may be difficult. Or maybe just go.
你知道，我们确实有绿卡。我们作为永久居民合法地待在这里。唯一的问题是，我们的绿卡将在一年或两年内续签。所以我们必须决定。要么我们决定全力以赴争取公民身份，要么续签。但续签可能很困难。或者也许干脆走人。
When she said this, I thought, but I want to stay. I really want to stay. And I want you to stay.
当她这么说时，我想，但我想要留下。我真的想要留下。我也想要你留下。
Six months ago, we had a big conversation about applying for citizenship. A few days later, I put in the form. But she never mentioned it again, so I knew she hadn't applied. This didn't feel like the time to bring it up.
六个月前，我们曾进行了一次关于申请公民身份的长谈。几天后，我提交了表格。但她再也没提过，所以我知道她没申请。现在这感觉不是提出来的好时机。
My more immediate concern is, you know, what's it going to be like living day to day in this climate and environment. I haven't shared it with you, but I had a very nasty experience just last week in the car park at Kroger.
我更迫切的担心是，你知道，在这种气候和环境下每天生活会是什么样。我没告诉你，但我上周在Kroger超市的停车场有过一次非常糟糕的经历。
Wait, wait. How did this happen?
等等，等等。怎么发生的？
Kroger's is the local supermarket. Apparently when she pulled in, she had to stop suddenly to avoid a guy going out of the store with his kids. Thinking nothing was wrong, she parks in the spot right next to the guy. She was with my kid sister Marissa, who's 16.
Kroger是当地超市。显然当她开进去时，她不得不突然停车以避开一个带着孩子走出商店的男人。觉得没什么不对劲，她把车停在那男人旁边的车位上。她和我那16岁的妹妹玛丽莎在一起。
And he was clearly saying something and mouthing off inside the car. So I stopped. And then he rolled his window down, and then just sort of a whole torrent of abuse at me.
他显然在车里说了什么并嘀咕着。所以我停下了。然后他摇下车窗，然后是一连串针对我的谩骂。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
Oh, how I should and shouldn't be driving in the car park and blah blah, and I'm speeding around the car park. And I said, uh, no, in fact. I was actually being very careful. And I said, well, you really don't need to worry. I'm always very careful. And then he started shouting, get away from my car. Don't touch my car. I said, I'm not touching your car. I'm not doing anything. I'm standing here.
哦，我应该和不应该如何在停车场开车之类的，说我在停车场里超速。我说，嗯，不，其实。我其实非常小心。我说，好吧，你真的不需要担心。我一直非常小心。然后他开始大喊：离我的车远点！别碰我的车！我说，我没碰你的车。我什么也没做。我就站在这儿。
And he was just saying, get away from my car. If you don't get away from my car, I'm calling the police. At which point, you know, Marissa started saying, Mommy, Mommy, just leave it. Just leave it. So you know, [INAUDIBLE]. And then it totally just finally hit me, I was thinking, oh my god. And looking at the guy, his face the way-- and suddenly I realized what it was all about it. It was a racial thing.
他只是在说，离我的车远点。如果你不离我的车远点，我就要报警了。就在那一刻，你知道，玛丽莎开始说：妈咪，妈咪，别理他。别理他。所以你知道，[无法听清]。然后它彻底击中了我，我当时在想，我的天。看着那个男人，他的脸的表情——突然间我意识到这一切是关于什么的。那是种族问题。
You know that trope about immigrant kids translating for their parents who don't speak English? It's true even for parents who speak the Queen's English. My sister translated the situation for my mother.
你知道关于移民孩子为不说英语的父母翻译的桥段吗？这即使对于说标准英语的父母也适用。我妹妹为我妈妈翻译了当时的情况。
You know, Marissa, she was really going on and on  at me. She was just saying, Mommy, why did you bother to talk to that man? Couldn't you have realized? You understand. I said, well, I don't know. Clearly, I'm missing something because I don't see what I have to understand. And she said, he's a white man with his two children. If the police had come, they wouldn't have listened to you. They would immediately have taken his side. And they would have done something bad to you.
你知道，玛丽莎，她真的不停地对着我唠叨。她只是说，妈咪，你为什么要费心和那个人说话？你难道没意识到吗？你懂的。我说，好吧，我不知道。显然，我错过了什么，因为我没看出我有必要懂什么。她说，他是一个带着两个孩子的白人。如果警察来了，他们不会听你的。他们会立即站在他那一边。而且他们会对你做坏事。
And I said, do you really believe that? And she said, oh, I know it. She said, you don't seem to understand, Mommy. I've actually grown up in this country. You haven't. And you don't understand how these people are and how they think. But that's what would have happened to you. And it was just really, really horrible, and it really shook me up badly.
我说，你真的相信吗？她说，哦，我知道。她说，你不明白，妈咪。我其实是在这个国家长大的。你没。你不了解这些人是什么样以及他们怎么想。但那确实会发生在你身上。那真的、真的太可怕了，它真的让我极其不安。
Then came the words I'd been dreading.
接下来是我一直担心的那些词。
I was just thinking, I think it's time for our American experiment to end.
我当时在想，我觉得我们的“美国实验”该结束了。
I was actually thinking you were going to say that. I don't know. For some reason, that was my first reaction to the news, was that's what Mommy's thinking.
我其实以为你会这么说。我不知道。出于某种原因，我对这新闻的第一反应就是那是我妈妈会想的。
[CHUCKLING] Well, yeah. Sort of like--
[轻笑] 好吧，是的。就像——
But I mean, where would we go? Is Britain that much better?
但我指的是，我们能去哪儿？英国真的好那么多吗？
Well, the thing is, it's all about the devil you know.
好吧，问题是，那都是关于“你所熟悉的恶魔”。
The Britain my mother grew up in wasn't exactly thrilled with the immigrants streaming in from its former colonies. And Brexit has brought back a lot of those anti-immigrant sentiments in the UK. My mom was born in Britain to Dominican parents. And my dad moved there from Ghana when he was eight. The US is still a place she doesn't understand, especially after what she's seen in this election. She's mentioning fears I haven't heard in a very, very long time.
我妈妈长大的英国并不怎么欢迎从前殖民地涌入的移民。而脱欧带回了英国许多那种反移民情绪。我妈妈出生在英国，父母是多米尼加人。我爸爸八岁时从加纳搬到那里。美国依然是一个她不理解的地方，尤其是在她这次选举中所见之后。她提到的恐惧我很久很久没听过了。
It used to be a regular nightmare of mine, was one of you children being shot dead. Why live here if you don't have to? If you have option to be elsewhere, why choose here? And quite honestly, I've lived my whole life being symbolic black, and I'm quite happy to do that. But really, I suppose I don't feel valued enough by this society to do what it takes to live here and to struggle and to try to make the difference in order to make this place better.
这曾经是我噩梦的一部分，是你们孩子中的一个被枪杀。如果不必，为什么要住在这里？如果有选择去别处，为什么要选这里？说实话，我这辈子一直是个象征性的黑人，我很高兴那样做。但真的，我想我觉得这个社会对我不够重视，不足以让我为了住在这里、为了挣扎、为了努力带来改变以让这个地方变得更好而付出代价。
My mom and I talk about race and our place in the world all the time. My entire life, the message has always been, rise to the challenge. When you're the only one, be the best, and make it easier for the black people who follow you. So hearing this stuff is devastating. She's the one who's supposed to have a good attitude about this.
我妈和我一直都在谈论种族和我们在世界上的地位。我的一生，信息总是：面对挑战。当你作为唯一的一个人时，表现得最好，让跟随你的黑人更容易些。所以听到这些事太毁灭了。她本应该是对这事持积极态度的人。
[SIGHS] OK, Mommy. I don't know. I think it's all--
[叹气] 好吧，妈咪。我不知道。我觉得这一切——
Were you hoping that talking to me, you'd feel better?
你是不是希望跟我谈谈，你会感觉好一点？
Yeah, I know.
是啊，我知道。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Don't worry about this country. As they say, a country gets the government it deserves. So you know, good luck to them with it. And you just take care of yourself and just carry on being the decent person that you are. And try to love everybody. And that's all we can do.
别担心这个国家。俗话说，一个国家得到它应得的政府。所以你知道，祝他们好运。你照顾好你自己，继续做你那个正派的人。试着爱每一个人。这就是我们能做的一切。
Yeah.
是啊。
OK, my dear?
好吗，亲爱的？
OK.
好的。
Love you, darling.
爱你，亲爱的。
I love you.
我也爱你。
Bye.
再见。
Emmanuel Dzotsi. He's one of the producers of our show.
伊曼纽尔·佐齐。他是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "IT SEEMED THE BETTER WAY" BY LEONARD COHEN]
[音乐 - 莱昂纳德·科恩的《It Seemed the Better Way》]
Well, our production staff, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Zotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Research help for today's show from Michelle Harris, Benjamin Phelan, and Christopher Sewtala. Music help from Damien Graef.
那么，我们的制作人员，苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·切斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明、卡伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、斯蒂芬妮·福、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯、本杰明·费兰和克里斯托弗·苏塔拉。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life was delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's got a new hobby. He bought himself a priest outfit. And he likes to go to bars, walk up to people, stand very close, take out his Bible, take out a cross, and ask for their confession.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所发送到公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他有个新爱好。他买了一套祭司装。他喜欢去酒吧，走到人们身边，站得非常近，拿出圣经，拿出十字架，并请求忏悔。
Everything changes. Even if they're holding a drink, they'll put it down.
一切都在变。即使手里拿着饮料，他们也会放下。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。